[Music]
and direct posting of the Cowboys hearts
on face
it is a brown can karate dress and now
ladies and gentlemen senior a senior e
the kid from Albuquerque
Alec I don't know how to say kid Natalia
but anyway this Frederica
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my love and my Mew hard to ever kind
what do what do what to do my love like
mime you can't make up his mind
[Music]
what to do what to do what to do crazy
critter so doggone arbitrary I get the
jitters just talking to the prairie they
don't care they don't care they don't
care they don't care what's do what to
do what to do they break every brother
it's quite a routine when a man and a
dorky can both make a murky at one
pigheaded
[Music]
my love and mom you believe me it's
cruel and I quote and unquote
[Music]
Oh take your pardon I thought this is my
room
indeed the piece match myself well I I
don't think I know you to your long list
of admirers Mademoiselle I would like
myself to be added thank you I
congratulate you on your singing thank
you very much and it occurred to me you
might care to join me for a late supper
sorry
I'm sure Mademoiselle most tired of
restaurant up with my vida not just the
two of us can now look but why don't you
forget the whole thing and go home and
shave Mademoiselle you are a stranger in
a strange country all I have done was to
offer my own sweet dollars and all I'm
saying is thanks many but when you
please get out of here Mademoiselle
there is no need to lose your temper if
one is young and beautiful one must
expect you think if the gentleman is
annoying you I should be pleased to
remove him maybe you could save me the
trouble your names in your air my name i
it is distasteful to me Senora to fight
a duel be very period I do
are you kidding not at all what more
there unless the gentleman apologizes as
he leave their own I do apologise
Mademoiselle I I think that no and now
all you do good night good night
hey do you really go around stabbing a
people I have learned my more self that
if one threatens loudly enough who one
never has to fight say you're pretty
smart
I accept your compliment when Moselle
and she'd like to return it I found your
performance enchanting much obliged for
many nights I've watched you not only
with admiration but Envy beyond
everything else in the world I wanted to
be a single what stopped you
unfortunately circumstances compel me to
enter my father's business
Oh what do you do I work for the
government
Oh lots of people do that at home - sure
one here hi well I have to change my
costume
imagine the impertinence a complete
stranger asking you to go with him to
his villa without a chaperone
I to a revealer only 50 kilometers for
me but would I ask you to go with me to
it without a chaperone
Oh certainly not of course at this hour
it might be difficult for me to find one
well I could find a chaperone
you could sure Georgie hoskinson's
California cowboy all of them Imperial
Imperium well nah thanks a lot but good
night
but Morty this is Italy out there is the
Mediterranean over it the most beautiful
moon I love Italy and the moon of course
you do not get all of it every night
right from my balcony I sit out there
with a chicken sandwich and a glass of
milk
all by myself and love it what a waste
of the Mediterranean
good night Jim kill him
good night but was it you are married
not me oh that is a pity
a great pity because if man was ever
Madame it would be quite correct for me
to kiss her end
[Music]
thus but since Martel is unmarried one
is only permitted to save the hand oh
[Applause]
[Music]
well if I ever do get me right now but
you know good night
how do you idiot out of the ditch
I'll be see
hello Jim
buona sera signorina chicken sandwich
good lesser milk
Samantha sinister Circosta signorina
centralist
that's a coaster always the same thing
Java Brava senior ena well I'm learning
Gracia going on up a senior now take to
your famiiy
oh well well and what a coincidence
well isn't it and I don't think I like
it
no there's a nice couple living in that
room they were from Texas Dex is it what
happened to them they are extremely
happy in a deluxe suite at the same
price I thought you had a villa near
here
I do it was my trouble to have my
suitcases back okay No
do you balance scenery that you just
said there's either a park across
ahlstrom no the last word ow
hmm what does it mean it means your
royal highness
why did you call you there for because
of a very unfortunate accident Oh bird
forgive me but I am Prince Alexei de
Labarre the Corporon Torpy Prince Alexei
- just call me al
your highness yes the whole thing is
what we call it setup isn't it yes what
I mean it you got plans yes and this
routine Ellen you've used it many times
before
yes usually with great success sometimes
or not often I'm sure but sometimes a
failure yes that's both I should have
recognized you you picked it in the
paper often enough you're always winning
medals for climbing mountains aren't you
yes well your highness I hope you
realize you're not going to win any
medals tonight yes
well as long as we understand each other
there is no reason why I should not see
Pierre him to enjoy the Mediterranean
the Mediterranean went bad away I am
supremely content with the view
perhaps I can tempt you with a little
champagne my friend
you can't tempt me a period it well not
that I don't admire your technique that
makes you go to that man with a beard
not baloney about a duel and getting
those nice Texas people to move
champagne caviar the moonlight the
Mediterranean why can take no credit for
it Mediterranean mm-hmm will take about
for putting it to good use
[Music]
I knew there was something soft music
you do not like music oh I love it but
where the violin hi Olli
oh man who would think of everything
would surely think violin much more zel
I would consider violins extremely as
you say corny
[Music]
new hat I liked violins play beautifully
middle got you
[Music]
oh the scar your long and soon of your
heart
on dal-su 4-4 head
[Music]
before
Oh
we breathe
when I pee but beauty and life
[Music]
not oh please school
and me
[Music]
Spidey's are
[Music]
you are
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
that was Germany good night good night
oh I can't call you well I may call you
Frederick
Rodrigo Brown it doesn't see no I shall
call you right well it's an Italian war
but he prescribed me perfectly oh it's
one of those untranslatable words but
believe me my dear describe I like
well
good night a video T net
I do forget
[Music]
Retta shredder Frank ladies and
gentlemen the kid from Albuquerque must
better round hi Oh redder
it describes you perfectly well of all
the
pronto camera 2 is equal to perform
hello
forever
very funny what shredder
well aren't you I doubt what very very
Fred look your highness
I'm a tired working girl where are you
now
in my room I know but where I'm at the
telephone where is the telephone idiot
over there on the desk I was into this
strange in my room is by their bed so so
I were thinking come on
I was thinking that since you do not
trust me the moonlight perhaps tomorrow
and the sun is shining it would dry with
me my god
or we could send a little boat what
anything else you'd like to do nothing
fatal ever happens in the sunshine well
perhaps your hanging if you call me in
the morning then you do a text oh yeah
I trust you good night
you do trust you do trust me oh yes your
friend I trust you
[Music]
well where'd you find your little friend
he seems to have lost his father and
mother
what would here once upon a time a
castle
perhaps a watch tower built by the
Saracens
to have been the musical so that we
could enjoy the view well here comes his
family Jonathan yeah you know well bran
China Bambino you insulted him insulted
him from be know his baby like a sweet
boy Jonathan Athena is no longer
insulted from Journal
L
I don't know me
grittiness leave me
mighty mighty the only Italian I knew
before I came here was does spaghetti
and ravioli and now you know an empty
box
I know one more terrible
unbe armor button llamo means let's go
that's right let's go
let's go let's go
oh I forgot he's in Italian doctor Oh
what was that new order efficiently
Andiamo Andiamo my Babita its economy or
look around you what have you people to
accompany pesto pattern or mile of force
or desire
[Music]
hobby
Andiamo
tortha karf of fine we'll have pizza
antipasto I swear he good wine company
pressed for time
[Music]
IVA be taught in school economy or
[Music]
enorme my love was horny by ah
[Music]
[Music]
very good
[Music]
ha ha ha
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
oh she is beautiful on a clear day you
can see Corsica
gosh if the kids back in Albuquerque
could see me now you come here very
often yes
very oh oh who wins my little son
tell me about your son what would you
like to know well does it look like you
oh by an odd coincidence I just happen
to have these with me oh how old is he
not yet six and here I'd like one of
your Cowboys
I taught him what's he doing there
playing chess with my father the King I
taught him to box too you did indeed I
did and you know what happened he got
into a fight with the gardener's boy
eight years old three inches taller well
that wasn't so funny but it was it was
terribly funny one punch from the
gardener's boy and my little prince got
two beautiful black eyes he told me he
fell in the bathtub
you must be proud of him
very proud I bet he's proud of you too
for a whole year after we lost his
mother I never left the palace he gave
us a chance to become wonderful friends
what does they want to be when it grows
up oh I mean all I have son may be an
engineer doctor son may be a
prizefighter but when one is born in the
shadow of a throne one dies in that
shadow you don't want him to be a king I
do not
but if he were a good King and and he
ruled wisely a king does not rule he is
only a symbol I do not wish my son to be
a symbol and you you do not want to be a
king no I don't want to be a king but
for me it's too late
all my life I've accepted the privilege
of a prince therefore I cannot serve the
duties of a king when I was a little
girl I remember a story about a little
boy an ordinary little boy
one fine day he discovered that he had
been changed into a prince well why
can't it be the other way around perhaps
you can
la la la la la shirani
hologram attention for me to do
[Applause]
[Music]
come on we do we farm grandeur for the
other Selena Brown isn't that what you
know make them prepare not a chicken
sandwich in classroom milk of any
similar non-tournament Akari important
teaching no offense doc we stop your
reversing your unibrow
[Music]
what is it been and what is soldier each
of our saviors yes please
why didn't your telegram says it with
your own hands out of the country again
or put it in the water turn on first
time of centimeters pour upon I beg you
sir every minute counts a piece of paper
Benante penny pencil
[Music]
banan take my car go to the Riviera
telling Apollo and deliver these no to
is Federico Brown activities are seldom
secret sir but notice hardly necessary I
will handle this matter with my youthful
discretion these matter as you choose to
call it is not usual do we deliver this
note to me Brown and follow me on the
earliest plane
[Music]
oh I expected I know you are Miss Brown
yeah my name is van and I hope it will
forgive this inclusion but I come to you
with a message from His Royal Highness
there's something wrong
I'm afraid so three days ago
His Majesty His Royal Highness father
became seriously ill thus mourning his
condition became critical naturally he
would want his son and heir at his side
Oh naturally I'm learning of the
seriousness of the situation His Royal
Highness was compelled to leave without
benefit of goodbye hi-c
His Majesty is not expected to live
hence His Royal Highness will become our
King I by the way and His Majesty's
Prime Minister and I brought you a
letter His Royal Highnesses regrets I
suppose with the practice won't you
become Kalos with new situations but
somehow I never find them easy what is
it that you don't find easy to say he's
over ours
His Royal Highness is so sentimental
goodbyes become impossible for you
fortunately one American Americans are
practical never thank you
what I've been through some of these
European women you have my sympathy I've
always heard that European women are
very even practical I see what about -
enjoy your supper Mademoiselle good
appetite
goodbye
oh I almost forgot if when Mademoiselle
is in Paris she would bear this Ducati
and select say some modest jewel that
might catch her fancy His Royal Highness
would be very grateful good night man
[Music]
[Music]
voltage Oh
[Music]
they feel emasculated a Hollywood
[Music]
wait for me I'll be about 10 minutes all
right mr. hundred kilometer honor hello
Mac knots we're shooting the test yes
they have just finished the last shot
sir Anna yeah yeah madam what time is it
oh I'll just about major oh hello
darling I want to talk to you I want to
talk to you too
let me get out of this now be right with
you we've got to move fast
yes madam did you talk to Palm Springs
yes madam everything arrange everything
mother you check with the airport no
matter it was too early but I think I
know we can get information
oh wait you're not going with me madam
no why I'm driving down alone but I have
engaged a horse doctor one for my number
one for me I know Anna but I've never
kept any secrets from you ever never
madam I'm keeping it they could come you
know I know madam what do you know that
ever since you'll see if the telephone
call from Paris
Madame has been full of very much
secrets but I understand well if you do
and you just might see that no one else
does oh no no one Madame come in Paul
have a cup of coffee down in my chain
thank you I don't mind beautiful I'd
like to be alone with miss Barlow human
to you I do not know buffet English Anna
who's Minister Fayyad to make that phone
call outside yes madam I thought you
didn't understand English not one world
what do you think of Bolton good actor I
thought he was great I think we gotta
look better
oh we've tested over 20 I brought them
from New York from London from anywhere
I can find them
hey Stella Bolton's played all the kings
there are Richard Henry yeah just what
is it you're looking for
mm-hmm something when I find it Oh No do
this for me Dad uh-huh honey I want to
talk to you about something yeah this is
a third picture together I think it's
gonna be our best mm I think so too
when you first brought me the story
frankly I was again at American girl
falls in love with a king it seemed
old-fashioned now somehow I believe it
I've always believed it pause okay so
this is our third picture together
still no contract just a handshake
what's wrong with a handshake nothing I
like it give me a chance to hold your
hand looks like I fell okay I'll make
plans how about a handshake for free
okay fine why not ten pictures more so
that's what's worrying you look darling
a star can't get any better than the
best and you're the best a one world
would I ever want to go anyplace out
yeah that's fine
it's fine but there's a little more to
it than that look further five pictures
10 pictures 10 years 20 years there's
still all that time all that time
between pictures when I don't even see
it doesn't make sense I'm gonna work
together we'll be together not just a
studio not just but dinner
Paul are you asking me to marry you I'm
not asking you to run for Congress
why didn't you wait until Monday known
each other three years this is Friday
you should have waited till Monday okay
honey I'll compromise give me a renter
tonight
I can't see you tonight no no I I'm
going out of town oh where you going
I'll be back Monday Monday
and on Monday I said to you please miss
Barlow would you better leave
I don't for someone else over the
weekend
you don't
that's their magic handshake goodbye
that had been away from home too
you
[Music]
Palm Springs one four nine seven
hello allow me to cover this is Anna
Anna
mr. hollows makes for three hours I am
calling him from Los Angeles no no no
the father she should be there any
minute now
who me no I am NOT coming I am sick
there he dick miss Bardot wants you to
know she wants only one room no no no
she does not want you to lose money if
you cannot rent the other room she will
pay for him but please please you tried
to rip the other room well I'll see what
I can do goodbye gran make this phone
come she's coming but she only wants one
room please put these in the East Room
put these back the woman closet
Mike why track for a change
nevertheless put the towels in the East
Room Yes Doctor
the East Room grim yes auntie my rank
Kabul I'm mrs. Cabot huh one may enter
of Commerce
my name is Imperium Imperia Imperial I
thought that's what you said Imperium I
have just arrived from Paris from Paris
well that seems extraordinary oh well it
is my understanding Madame that you have
a room for it
well how'd you hear about it if we don't
advertise where you've seen Paris it was
very cold and very wet
I hate your desert was very Mormon very
dry I like warm weather but very warm
here the water that is what the weather
is what I refer to mother I thought
that's what you mean
and so madam I boarded a plane through
to Palm Springs but unfortunately
without reservations I have tried the
half a dozen different hotels and at one
of them one of the clerk said that you
occasionally rented rooms and area well
it just so happens by the merest
coincidence that I do have a vacancy
good I get my back out there all right
out there uh company I'll show you what
I've got
it may not be elegant enough for you
whom I find usually reflects the
personality of each occupant in this
instance I have no feelings mother
oh that's nice of you just say it was
nothing madam nothing at all this is the
rest room it just things the East Room
except it's a it's wet I can't these are
the best well the bank you complete
neither on your life yeah the dressing
rooms over there you don't have to pay
attention that door we did the other
room the doors bolted on both sides
a wise precaution I'm sorry there isn't
want to get your bags for you you'll
have to amend yourself Oh God
my boy Sam
mr. param huh what he said
imperium there's no such name tears must
be I was just think he's somebody I
don't know first of all I thought he was
a horror movie star like Charles Boyer
he's not Charles Boyer well anyway he
looks like an actor if he is one is
follow I'll know who he is definitely I
laughter you're doing nothing to that
sort get your people
Nancy the only reason she comes here is
because so quiet you know whatever
bothers are asking the questions
including you Father
Oh mr. Imperium
there's my niece Gwendolyn but more than
delighted how do you do I just ain't no
Andy I know I've seen you before your
pictures on a grand oh I don't mean to
be rude mr. Imperium but haven't I been
at for more saline another life we were
friends Oh Jerry I want a perfectly
treat me fire a gun darling if we're
going to movies tonight you've got your
homework to do yes ante up now darling
yes auntie re-pour morning why of course
you don't realize it but that's you
never ride one minute earlier I wouldn't
had a room she can sew their own just
before you rang the doorbell
you see she always observes both rooms
that so she'll be disturbed run to
strangers anything but at exactly one
minute to her maid called and then the
clock struck three who's me miss Barlow
gotta borrow whatever power oh yeah hey
you've seen it in person on this
beautiful yeah we're surfing and makeup
just little lipstick named to the powder
so tell the truth down here just lie
about the Sun with nothing on Oh Micah
funny I do from maybe what you're
talking about
I can't understand it giving up one of
the rooms seems so peculiar because
money can't mean anything to us you'll
forgive me if I don't introduce you to
miss Barlow she's really very sweet
nothing brand about her what they have
sort of an understanding we never
introduced hurt anyone
I
will be very undemocratic matter don't
believe me please bottle
oh well you forgot to tell me how long
you want the room until the 17th their
17th that would be Monday would it oh
well today's Friday is it oh yes of
course the 17th will be Monday thank you
Miss Imperium mr. Imperium at Imperium
that's what he says his name is yeah I'm
doing as a for never denoise son yeah
shut up or something oh I suppose I
don't mind
sergeant Paragons with her
it was the strangest thing this bottle
just after hung up the phone I talked to
your main the bell rang there stood mr.
Imperium wasn't the most amazing
coincidence amazing Gwen will you please
put these the bathrooms he's singing
again
would you excuse me as follows yes when
I don't believe me
yeah I know I've seen him in something
in something the Monkees I mean of
course it's not a start we didn't know
right away who he is but he must be an
actor I can tell I know I've seen him in
follow I just haven't seen you
well can actually have but at any rate I
shall see no one for the next few hours
I'm exhausted
may I draw the drapes for you I mean
that would be wonderful
he good-looking isn't he who mr.
Imperium I'm afraid I didn't notice well
if there's nothing else I can do nothing
else thank you
I asked you not to sing anymore he was
very nice about it well why did you do
that so you can rest miss Barlow oh well
that was kind of you and offense well
rest well I'll try
Frederico Brown her majesty
[Applause]
for 12 years I have waited for this
moment why are you wait come on all
through the war I will replace an
Aramaic Palace I know I prayed for you
then there was the revolution and the
government in exile in Paris when I
learned what been and had done to her
and I was free to hope for you
there was no Frederic around but by name
hadn't changed I was easy to find so
many times I wanted to write well why
didn't you
it took a long time for me to forget a
long time to fall in love with someone
else someone else then the phone rang
and the operator said parents calling
and then I heard you fly and I hadn't
forgotten you at all that what I waited
to read
[Music]
only thing even in Hollywood Li we do
read the newspaper and what do you eat
the next Tuesday there will be a pleb
side no people will go to the polls to
vote you back on to the throne
you'll be a king again and I shall
that's it
[Music]
on Thursday Neff there will be police
and my people will go to the polls but
we would against me goodbye the time
being I am here with you to stay if you
[Music]
we're in Paris so busy with his
government-in-exile probably going after
will mind trying to find me he found you
once before this time I came to clever
no one knows I am here except asleep
my darling on Tuesday next baby kicking
with our to throw
a commoner in not disappoint
still resting she must have been tired
this man Tyrion was tired too but
doesn't air that's a new name for it
what do you talk about when Oh aunty
don't be so unsophisticated even mrs.
Cavett
when won't you join us I'm enough thank
you
well there's plenty here we're going to
movie afterwards would you like to go
with it well thanks very much but it's
such a lovely night I thought I'd take a
little drive and get a bite of dinner
and then come back to bed I hope their
periods all right we haven't seen him
since I shot in the road Oh what to do
what to do what to do forgive me madam
I forgot my promise I think you've got a
wonderful voice miss imperium you could
be a non-profit
are you flattered me man was there I bet
without my accent you would all think me
a cowboy well we even with us oh what a
wonderful evening everybody pay me
compliment that's a very old song
where'd you learn that
Amy silly madam and you remembered it it
was younger not too well mind you by a
very beautiful woman I remember the
woman and therefore the tongue oh I
think that's charming mr. imperium don't
you follow Oh charming not original mind
you but charming madam there is so much
regionality in the world and so little
child for example for example for us to
dine together would not be very original
but it would be charming well the
restaurants here rather limited to me
mr. imperium you suggest caviar
champagne on the contrary mother I am
the chicken sandwich and a glass of milk
I well we can do better than that
there's a little place halfway up the
mountain charcoal-broiled stink
please borrow you have talked me into it
Mademoiselle mano had my view we didn't
even have to do a thunk
I tell you auntie there's something
squeeze you about the whole thing
Renji in the first place tearing up the
room then going off with him a stranger
just like that and why should a
foreigner sing cowboy song I don't know
there but your uncle was an American and
he loved to sing o Sole Mio of course
that was different he really never knew
the words I must find some way to make a
living we think inventory I could
picture dancing singing boxing chess
horseback riding but I don't like to
beat
over at an antique shop cool I think all
clocks and make them into Lance I pick
old banks and make them into clock
arrests Dora
why didn't we think of this before
restaurant driving Beverly Hills
I came to choppa know as please in
America your success stories very calm
like a poor hunter
I read in the magazine he started by
selling his people industry they say
that about most successful man but a
party that happens to be true anymore
lucky what do you want to know
everything well he's tall dark
intelligent and sometimes quite him God
and he's in love with and do is not tell
me about the other picture what is
[Music]
an American girl falls in love with a
king what a coincidence
innit who we please King we don't know
we've tested more than a dozen actors
but there's always something missing
[Music]
better how would I put okay how would
you autograph for a thousand years
actors have grown wealthy playing kings
it would be a beautiful event what a
wonderful country is America all these
moments ago I am a lowly restaurant
proprietor now I am top of the picture
co-star yeah well in my new success I
can afford to be generous in this
picture glama country
oh yeah I think I can do that very
common you're serious
never have I'd be more suited on my life
perhaps you're born we thinking about
the time I Paul has a wonderful eye for
talent
everything okay folks you have no idea
how okay would you mind miss Berlin not
at all
[Music]
thank you very much next year I feel
time due to rampu miss Imperium I want
you to meet the Guadalajara tree how do
you do how do you start your picture
miss Barlow he means when we work well
it won't be long now you have found
someone to play the King I think we have
to you I also sing oh I think you do
that in what language what you do one
number in Spanish word because these are
my friends and I want to give them a job
oh I suppose they ask them if they know
such-and-such a song and they will
answer yes well if they answered no
there wouldn't be any job literally now
let's see do you know where Solomon
[Music]
I mean not so lament ill of
[Music]
we weren't open your eyes fell hard
nice parents like your own Riley Camino
they need solid on
Robert not
we get all the more call a goofy torta
[Music]
nada mas and we were hoping you're nice
there are nice parents archaeal umbrella
common order he's solid
or everything I can see in everything
you move along to my heart and our Lord
snow we were gathering stars where army
lead our law
when I said I love you every beat of my
heart said ha woman and your eyes
[Music]
darling you are the song and you'll
always feel
[Music]
[Laughter]
you notice her car isn't here yet maybe
she put it around on the other side of
the house
Oh auntie hey I'm home their doors are
still open their lights out and it's
after 11 doesn't take that long doesn't
take that long for bought to eat steak
and potatoes they might have known
forgot there's nothing wrathful about a
drive well she said she came down you to
rest she rested all afternoon
how do you know the drapes are going so
we're his so we're just one face John he
rested too
I wonder when dairy doesn't good for you
to wonder so much but I do wonder aunty
what about for goodness sakes
Oh aunty I don't mean to be rude really
I don't but I guess I guess when you get
old it just get my Eve really what would
you say if the doors between their rooms
were unlocked - well they couldn't be
derelict to myself this morning but
suppose they were unlocked now oh good
heavens clean no it's one way to find
out come on
[Laughter]
[Music]
and now long edits are una is not of us
oh I've done it again forgive me I
really meant to keep my promise oh
that's all right with Imperium
you sounded so happy happy how could one
else but be happy and right through the
knife is so beautiful a companion of
course I am happy are you happy to miss
Barlow ah Oh ever so happy full of good
food clean desert air and all of a
sudden I'm utterly exhausted I'm night
oh what a wonderful place to rest these
days well goodnight Barlow and thank you
so much for a delightful evening
I enjoyed it good life and blessed be
the coincidence who knows what may
happen next I hope he hasn't made a bore
of himself oh no miss Cabot Bowen is
hardly the word what is the word miss
Barlow the word I never could find the
right word when I wanted it but believe
me my dear it isn't bored
good night mm-hmm there you see he's
gone to his room and she's on her way to
her I can't imagine what makes you think
the things you do
maybe Dresden squidgy come on time to go
to bed
long distance please
I want Beverly Hills Crestview five four
one two four a one four nine seven and
Cooling Paul it's pretty late
well he has a full bath bed oh yeah
Betty well I imagine he has most
executives do you know so I didn't know
well now you do
hello hello Paul did I wake you no I'm
glad you don't oh that's sweet of you
darling
what time oh yes darling of course
darling
show business everybody calls everybody
darling Oh what darling no no I was just
talking to a friend well you don't know
him Paul it's a very old friend
and Klaus the most extraordinary thing
but he would be absolutely marvelous at
the king she wants him to play the king
the terrible part is His Majesty would
be superb yes really yes I have every
confidence in your enthusiasm but why
didn't you suggest him before he wasn't
available now mr. hunter you see how
serious this is
I've important it is that something
should be done at once hello I've got
too much at stake
Fred of us make a wrong decision what's
that really I said we'll come in tonight
and call Anna for me will you darling
tell her to prepare the guest room well
I am I'm only being hospitable and then
Paul be at my house at 10 in the morning
please do what well yes I know tomorrow
isn't Monday well I can't talk about it
over the phone you haven't
I well not now darling please that's
right
in the morning at 10:00 by stayed home
Olli why he said he didn't want to take
a chance of falling in love with someone
else
obviously you know gambler darling we've
got to pack and drive to Beverly we
better get started before we before we
what before we forget a lot of things
that simply have to be remembered for
instance for instance a three-hour drive
to Beverly Hills
a drive to Beverly Hills was not exactly
what their plan darling will you get
that antenna legal majesty
[Music]
oh forget it
good we would be perhaps paid a visit
now there'll be nothing to see except
some empty stage in the Nightwatchman I
have always liked fashionable resorts
after season
all right there is something I'd like to
show you it's at
[Music]
come on I want to really show you
something
now you wait right here
well well well what a coincidence isn't
it what happened to those wonderful
people from Texas
oh they struck oil they all we do is
battle oh yes
these old thing is what we call in
America is it up yes you have plans yes
you have done this before
oh yeah and always raise great success
yes and sometimes not very often
sometimes a page yes tonight you will
have no failure I am what you call not
hard to get you have suspected this
[Music]
it is incredible my darling that one man
could be so happy and at the same time
so hungry hmm me too
now we have to find a name for you I
have a name oval Imperial it's fine but
I mean we have to get it first me but I
also have a friend named Alexi you know
I know Alexi the gamble to go to
something other know something simple
like Joel George herring Sam ignite
beautiful sad overthrown starring at the
bar low and bigness Oh that'll be poor
now listen darling don't be overeager
just let him do most of the talking and
when it comes to money I'll handle that
not that Paul is in generous but after
all he is a businessman and a million at
[Music]
matter
I bring you mr. hunters apologies but he
felt that his presence would lend
further embarrassment to an already
awkward situation no apologies are
necessary Batman no one in the world
could be more welcome I was just
beginning to worry about how I could
find you but I should have known
like a bad penny you turn up at the
opportune moment forgive me miss Barlow
you do remember that man yes I seem to
remember that we did meet once before
I'm sure madam understands by now the
throw things in the course of our duties
I understand many things bananas but not
what brings you here but I understand
Fred there he's come about the Flemish
side
haven't you been mad about this speech I
am to make on Tuesday exactly
your madness is on schedule departure
from Paris please the vacuum that was
not precisely part of our plan oh yes
our plans that's what I want to see you
about the man I think you should know
that there has been a slight alteration
in our plans there is hardly time for
alterations your majesty the speech must
be made on Tuesday or else no my friend
on Tuesday you will tell our people
and doors the world that I renounced
your majesty
twelve years ago I made a grave mistake
it is from what by you only a fool would
lose the same battle twice so tell my
people where King has made his final
choice to spend the rest of his life
with the woman he loves
do you realize what you're doing Madonna
do you realize at the time there's no
letter for you to burn no lies that you
can tell Your Majesty I have no
intention of you look at yourself
they're not my abdication will take
place on Tuesday this is only Saturday I
am still the king you may go surely Your
Majesty knows me well enough to know
that I would not only take this long and
tiresome journey without baggage baggage
its diplomatic language for the ace of
trunks come come you have baggage then
let us examine it by all means you know
madam after the war ended we had a
revolution who we find me farlow very
well informed good but this she may not
know our people now are weary of
revolution
they want their king again and they are
going to have a king if not the father
then they'll have for some their son
where is your son in England with good
friends enjoying life like any English
boy he loves his lightning and I'm told
if she was so cruel to put an end to it
put them into what his life to his life
in England oh were he he's bluffing my
boy is safe in England you know here's
my news is somewhat later than your own
then where is he the moment of his meds
he disappeared I took it upon myself to
communicate with the prince he is at
present somewhere on the continent and
the care of good and patriotic friends
if his majesty remain of silent then I
shall speak as his Majesty's death
and I shall tell our countrymen that
they are king deserted them in their
hour of need and that his son will come
to them in a reign under my Regency
until he comes of age my boy safe in
England where is your telephone oh right
here
one moment your attitude the United
States government has generously
provided the military airplane it is
waiting a gauge 44 of the Los Angeles
International Airport
there will be no publicity they will
respect your incognito I shall await you
there if any harm has come to my boy
please wait a moment
I want to talk to you
please
brunette I can't believe that you would
play the teenage boy I upon the throne
to to be a target for a bomb to be a
target is the destiny of anyone who
rules listen to me banana tomorrow I can
sign a contract for for 10 years I'll
give you half three quarters of my
salary more if you like yes if you'll
return the boy to England in let his
Majesty stay here with you and let his
Majesty stay here with me
I have never entered his majesty his
crown but we loved so deeply by one so
beautiful of that I am indeed in his
yes yeah that's right mr. Clifton Taylor
Amesbury school Sussex England thank you
David called right back it doesn't seem
possible that a prince to be kidnapped
without the whole world knowing about it
is the one thing I am counting on funny
in a moment like this when my old world
is falling to pieces to be concerned
with such a little thing that bow there
are nuns bow you didn't notice your
majesty your majesty that insulting
little bow from the neck it's all I get
from him he knows it infuriates that's
why I don't now my father your majesty
hello hello hello mr. Taylor this is
King galaxy speaking yes fine thank you
fine tell me I have been led to believe
that is there is a rumor that my son
what is that he did yes of course I'll
wait the boy was not kidnapped oh thank
heaven no leftover your own accord he
left a note to the headmaster he's going
to read it to me have you pencil in
paper yes yes yes mr. Taylor my country
is in danger and I can do no less then
go to AIRAID where my personal happiness
the only consideration I should like to
have remained in England forever with
those I love but I have been taught that
battles are never won by running away
Thank You mr. Taylor thank you 17 years
old
[Music]
you taught him to ride we taught him to
Bach perhaps she taught him this too
[Music]
arrivederci darling
[Music]
not even it
[Music]
thanks for coming okay he certainly was
the time he certainly was he didn't like
a pot
he didn't like the party laughter
five pictures 10 pages 20 if you like
between pictures all that time between
pictures further medic plan
he said out of a debt
what's at mean how be seen
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]